[Music]
hello guys this is Darius and today
again a saying in the end game
today's topic is just like last time
complex end games with many pieces not
like very simple ones like rookin games
there could be also rügen games but you
know with different bone structures is
about different bone structures which
makes them pretty complex so this is
primarily topic for today as well so
this doesn't waste any time and get
started so the first position I want to
bring today is the game from the game we
discussed last time upon me achieve a
Sheila graph and in this position I
remember I said that I wasn't sure what
happens after a night at 4:00 in his
position because I didn't kind of like
it was a holiday analysis it's a very
good question what happens because
blacks or blacks you know polish
basically falling what I said honestly
is also hanging so just to finish this
game quickly I want to start off this
one because just you know I found the
solution here so just want to show it
just Bishop e8 is good we need to
protect the point f7 pawn with the
epsilon protected afternoon h5 we can
play move Bishop to c1 and this suddenly
this night on 85 is not going anywhere
it's some sort of trapped okay of course
94 can come back but then you take the
for King takes the four were very likely
and in a draw so a 97 for instance
Bishop you just can go back home go
somewhere King f6 let's say after 97
just to quickly show Bishop c6 is
possible and the Bishop f7 is not really
possible because of King f6 and after
shopping after Bishop EA there is bishop
f3 and black with the knight on g7 so
it's not so simple to win this anymore
and to be honest I think this is already
a draw because I thought a 4 is the best
try but after takes takes f5
ninety-seven ignite the photos b56 and
this is what we should be seven-night is
pretty much trapped and the kind of
course is not really lost but you know
white cannot win this so I think it's
just dry even though white has two extra
pounds here so yeah this is the solution
the previous game that I want to talk
about in achieve a shallow graph let's
go to the next one just one moment and
the the first one I want to talk about
is actually game very old game by left
poke I have ski versus me loves Rothko
and this one my favorite actually games
that I've ever you know seen and I'm not
going to be talking too much about this
I'm just gonna show it and explain what
was happening was that correct done by
white and what is you know was the best
defense attempt by black however even
with the best defense is pretty hard
position to defend so as I say this is
one of my favorite personally and games
right now
poganski 95 takes on es c5 the rook
takes e5 97 and right now White has a
very important decision to make because
if black can play move 85 on the show it
h5 is back and go h5 then will be very
likely that position would be sort of
horrible because it's hard to make a
second weakness on the kingside however
it is of course white to play right now
in progress he certainly played move g4
and this is one of the typical moves in
end games that has to that very often
create some potential witnesses for our
point sometimes as black with a g5 wills
in some positions here the movies g4
because certainly white is better and we
need to create second weakness on the
kingside so this is
very nice way of converting beginning to
convert the advantage into into a full
point so in the game have enough 693 g5r
okay okay [ __ ] f7 f3 personally I'm
not sure whether a phrase correct move
and because I was probably just taking
g2 first maybe maybe h4 at some point
but f3 I'm not sure whether it's correct
in this moment because in general black
should try here in this position to play
through h5 and after f3 I think that h5
was by far the best defense in order to
simplify the position a little bit and
same thing applies after Kim G - but you
know this is in general the best defense
at least to try to simplify the position
at least slightly you know like if she
takes h5 rupees I suddenly becomes not
so clear because Paula h5 falls if H 3
or maybe King 8 free let's say H tech g4
h things before it's really one pawn
exchanged and it's black has some better
chances to survive this because with
less material on the board the
likelihood of making a draw surviving
the game is much higher than it is with
more pawns on the board
so this was the best defense here and
instead me left played rook e8 after
king f2 and I'd see it
he decided positive defense and passive
defense it is sometime sometimes works
but unfortunately it also very often
fails that's why I personally whenever I
can advocate for active defense because
they say there's the saying the best
defense is to attack so h5 here in this
position basically creating Condor
chances is counter attacking sort of
trying to you know get rid of some
weaknesses you know trying to actively
however now raakhi eight and and so on
was happening the game was passive
defense and this specific let's say
endgame it simply fails so of course
there's fortresses of course when
passive defense works and so I'm not
saying that both end games are not
that you have to basically go for a win
or like to look for our to condom no
chances in what when you have to look
for fortress but in this position
there is simply no default it's simply
not the fortress and it just is a
passive defense which doesn't work so
after Ruby 897 come back
Ruby 6 they repeated finally a bug ask
inside to take this rook King takes 895
rook c8 rogue a7 the past the first way
to win this is by maximized two Maxima
maximally opt activate pieces night and
rook and the King and second thing of
course create a second weakness so far
where is one weakness policy six and in
general problems on the Queen side
because it also can be considered as a
weakness but there were no problems on
the Queen side however second weakness
if this I mean this was all the only
weakness it would be black would be able
to deliver will live to live with it
however if we create second weakness it
is impossible for black to defend it
so Ruby eight kingi freaking f7 still
passive defense and finally progress key
found a path to create second weakness
and is basically move h4 and h4 already
you've hdhd 585 we have a five square so
Miller played h6 in North Bay its range
from h2 h3 five which would be
definitely in white favor
however we right now we move h5 with
fixed second weakness and this weekend's
pawn h6 we create a second witness of
the pollen h6 and there could be ideas
in of course long long perspective that
our rook can sometimes attack pawn on h6
or maybe you know maybe we can bring our
Knight to f5 is black does something
weird there could be some ideas here for
white to you know to make a good use of
respond on h6 the good which is
potentially a weakness so we love decide
to play rugby to it seems like it's an
active move but in reality it just stops
the king of to maneuver and bring the
King to the King side the Queen side
however right now again
bogus cappella for and the idea of a
four is to play with f5 after ob8 f5
the the idea of this is again to fix
other we can spawn f6 and most
importantly gain space gain essential
space because in this endgame with x2 so
much space white has clearly will good
winning chances pawn on pawns on c6 f 6
HS are all weaknesses our pieces are
let's say rook and Knight are the best
possible squares they can be right now
the only piece that needs to be improved
right now is the King so with the C
fixing of the post structure is not like
it's like all blocked and they push this
block because Chris eyes opened but
pawns on H 5 and a 5 simply create
potential weaknesses and actually the
early potential they are weaknesses on
f6 and h6 where which could be just
exploited in the very near future so
let's see how he managed to convert his
advantage roopd 8 and right now King
Geoffrey is beginning of the long plan
of bringing the King to the King side if
the King comes funny comes the King's
Queen side I meant King Queen so if the
King comes the Queen side its other
piece coming in and just support the
attack there procedure will be possible
some tactical ideas as we will see in
the game while simply dominating here
rook c8 let's say rube this ever
happened while the good moves blue comes
to d6 97 is there could be a threat were
threatening we just win this f6 pawn
somehow or c6 if let's say 97 IJ drops
in services will win the pond so
military look said in order to counter
97 with 98 and Ponzi's protected but
right now King comes to e2 and King goes
forward King goes on King c3 and king of
two before a 5 b6 and this pretty much
game over white rooks are white rook and
Knight are very powerful black is
completely stuck but cannot do anything
is personal is just one my favorite and
games just shows all kind of you know
aspects of
perfect and gameplay which is dunno
they're following the rules do not hurry
creating second weakness fully
activating the pieces including the king
so all those rules are fully satisfied
and what is simply winning here so rook
c8 route d6 again King goes again route
d7 through p8 right now like next one
I'd be seven kingdoms right now to the
whites blacks camp for c5 to d6 and
there is nothing black and Oh Roxy seven
located King c5 King comes to d6 came
over and as we see the material and
material balance is still equal however
positionally while is just crushing just
just completely when King comes to c6 e
six point the structure on King side is
fixed point on f6 is a weakness big
weakness point six is also a big
weakness porn h6 also will potentially
fall there is no way why black can
survive this this is just over so
personally as I say it's one of my
favorite and end games that I've ever
seen so I took him and but anyway pretty
complex because there are more pieces on
the board and there are lots of pawns to
pull you structure in the beginning is
not defined in the way poganski defined
the structure here is really impressive
in my opinion so this is the second game
and to talk about actually the first one
apart from mvl nuprin MVL and next one i
want to talk about is actually the games
from today I'm not sure whether we have
time for both of them but at least one
of them I serve things certainly think
that we can cover and the games from day
I'm I have I have in - from games from
the mini match between Magnus Carlsen
and Dingley run from chasuble masters so
the first one I want to talk about is
Magnus with white against England with
black and the game was after 18 moves we
got this position which is I think
theoretical one still
and happen from reducing Queens can be
declined Arrakis in variation and in
general I believe that this position
should be around equal there is no
really any serious reasons why black
should be worse here first of all the
yes there is isolated possible as well
pawn on d5 however there is policy free
that also requires attention material is
equal you know this isolated pawn is
pretty well defended by the knight and
the rook I don't know just seems pretty
equal to me like of course there are
some choices position is very playable
and that's why probably Magnus decided
to go for it because even though it's
probably very close to equality still
it's playable because there are pieces
on the board there to rupestre there is
a bishop versus night sometimes bishop
can be you know better than the night
especially there are ideas of g 4h for
g5
trying to key design of out of f6 there
could be idea of bringing this rook to a
one there are several plans for wider y
can choose depending what black does and
we'll discuss basically you know
everything that was happening because I
think this angles extremely interesting
so in the game disposition of course
akin D to in to provide the pawn and
right now black has two moves in my
opinion okay they're awesome
two main was there also lots of
alternatives that it's impossible to
cover in one lecture but basically two
plans either black face with rock a 5 or
without Luke a5 and to be honest both
look pretty good to me it's probably
personal preference which would like to
should choose but you cannot just go for
one and then they then side for the
other so in my opinion this basically
interview you have to be consistent so
in the game happened rook a5 just to
show quickly what can happen after Luke
ACA which is also perfectly legit move
rook a c8 it's also okay Bishop d3 let's
say King gave a true K 1 and a 5 and
this is a second plan of course just
quick note here dr. Bishop do you Roxy
free is impossible because Bishop c4
traps the rook disconnects the black
rooks and Pororo conceive free Falls but
why this is simply winning so King f8
rogue a 1 a 5 and yeah so the question
is what to do here win a war next with
white and to be honest probably white
should try at least to create some some
play on the King side by playing h4g 4
so this is what I was thinking maybe
like h4 here and for instance b6g 4
however black can simply play g5 of
course if white men still manages to
play g5 there could be some advantage
because neither promises kicked out and
pawn d5 let's say let's for instance
just example line the second g7 g5 is
this let's say Knight goes somewhere
here there could be ideas of bringing
this Bishop to f3 f4 Bishop e2 Bishop f3
also could be already possible to play
move before sometimes because pawn d5
will be falling so there there are some
certain issues nothing before I met Lee
is pretty good to be honest because
after takes takes takes rook takes d5
and rope only if I just fall so while we
just pawn up so therefore black
shouldn't be a should not allow this to
happen and black play simply move g5
knight on f6 has to stay I fall h5 could
be interesting similarly to what we
discussed in progress his game pawn h5
usually you know creates potential
witness for polymer h6 so it could be
tried here however I'm not really sure
whether it gives anything after it's a
ruby 7r ok - and move for instance kinky
7r ok - it doesn't really bring much
just sort of waiting move
I'm also rooks one is possible but after
let's say 97 you know I think black is
doing quite well the thing is before is
right now not so dangerous because a B
we cannot take with the pawn because
we're black is paint and if y the spin
demean and if knife comes to e5 c6 it
could be basically just equal so I
thought a for could be an attempt but
this days
six black suddenly get some counterplay
again black as defending side always try
to look for active contra player other
rather than passive counter play not
passive counter players kind of doesn't
even exist it doesn't exist just passive
defense usually active defenses better
than a passive defense and that's what
black should do here go immediately for
pal for active defense meaning 97-95
and if a four go attack the pudgy for
point and positions pretty much equal I
don't think black has a new reason to
suffer to worry about because if g5
didn't polish five falls
I think position just just okay for
black so in this position that I thought
maybe look a two but again this doesn't
really do any work in g7 Bishop e2 maybe
trying to prepare for at some point but
again just King g650 297 I don't really
see you know I had him pick at when any
serious let's say ideas for white could
any cause I mean real trouble for black
here so for instance Brooksie to also
consider but again 97 before takes takes
it's all very very close to equality
here for instance I like something like
this it's an example line I want to go
into details just general conclusion of
this position if King Gandhi 7 is that
it's pretty much around equal with
correct difference bucks should be able
to hold it so this was this is also a
very legit approach form for black to
play rogue 88 and then a 5 b6 bring the
King to the center and just stay and
make slowly when everyone given a chance
improve the night somewhere + c 2 c 6d
75 c 6 because white cannot really do
much here so this is one possibility
second possibility is what dignity REM
played in the game okay five after okay
five Magnus played Bishop d3 which is a
very good move Luke a4 wouldn't have
given much because after takes takes
King f8 White's pawn structure is messed
up here at least post
is good if one's a freebie free the
about the rugae for this disc Inga fate
position is pretty much equal I don't
think there are any real chances for
white to win this maybe somehow to a c4
at some point but you know structure a
structure wise there are no any problems
for black because you know black has
free app three point line it's a pop3
point Islands same as white so I don't
really think that you know there are any
real transition for white to win so
Bishop the freak happen which is very
logical move idea is of course we're
okay - Bishop c2 to cover on the second
rank and right now
King Lear had some choice and he chose
the wrong in my pen because he claimed
of 97 he tries to improve the night but
the thing is he tries he mixes up plans
like if you want to go 97 why do you
need to get 5 to do it instead of just
play rock I see it may be them try to
play 97 when a given a chance this well
we discuss right now after Lucchesi 8
instead if we go ok 5 just go for ok to
like be consistent this is wine I decide
is inconsistent and gives white some
chances to get some advantage
that's why I'll play also just playing
here ok - and after Bishop see - for
instance move like b5 also rook c8 is
possible also it was pretty good but we
know beef I was also interesting to be
honest both moves look pretty good to me
if rook see it let's say I was thinking
maybe we'll get four anyway but again
similar position to be true to the one
we just discussed after rook c5 say b6 I
don't see I don't think that there are
any problems here for for black so of
course there could be some issues slow
small issues that they were connected
with some Ruby 5 however black should be
able to defend it be files alternative
which is very concrete alternative let's
say if G for right now rook c8 h for
typical plan of course to play
but again we just go g5 and I don't
think that there are any insert anyway
real problems here for black again
regarding to is were active piece pins
on the second rank Rubens he had also
put some pressure on c3 pawn idols I
don't think that there could be any real
ideas here for for white to win this of
course and additional ideas for black is
of course play maybe at some point
a5 or maybe if even if not a five before
or a5 a4 it's possibly just to stay in
place with King g7 and maybe rock c7 and
just make some feel few moves like that
maybe even come back racing through a c6
nothing wrong that either
I just don't think what has here any
space any special advantage anything
special here so this was the right
approach basically to go rogue a5 just
go rogue a to activate your rook to the
full potential rather than just player
k5 and after after that 97 which is
pretty much inconsistent and least so
after King c-13 good move Ruka one of
course B should be one bug is okay so
right now the England's had to come back
with c5 so my question is why why to
play rogue a five rook c5 when you know
what ways Tempe like that it's not just
play rogue 88 and immediately here and
you have everything what do we what do
you have in the game but you know just
much better version and was wasting
Tempe 45 or a 565 so yeah 97 king c1 and
rook c5 king bee to rook happened rook
e8 all logical move so far obi-wan and
right now it was again critical position
because it was again moment good moment
for black to realize too that night
belongs on f6 pretty much that has to
defend this d5 pawn and it was time to
you know stabilize the position a little
bit because first of all before the fret
so you need to defend defenses d5 pawn
and by play Knight e5 it doesn't really
solve any problems because
of the tactics that Magnus has in this
position is one thing but also a knight
on e5 doesn't really help with
protecting ddg-51
even this tactic was not there 25 would
be always sort of a problem that's right
night belongs on f6 where it covers this
F from f6 d5 pawn and there is no I I
think basically that you know position
is still even though as far as a slight
bar for white but it's not easy to
convert that for instance knife six
before book seven bishops e2 neither
here to bring that to be Bishop to b3
and the five point but anyway Ruby five
we should be free that's a brook c7 Ruby
free protein in the point in g5 and to
be honest of course what's better right
now because it's a clear progress to
what we discussed let's say few moves
earlier wide manage to play before bring
this Bishop to be free protect fully on
if free right now after H free the
second comes to be to pony free is also
protected however it's blacks peas are
much worse than earlier in case of disre
graduated immediately and there are
certain ideas for white to slowly
improve the position and maybe somehow
double on the defiled bring the King to
f2 many play room do you want the attack
on d5 maybe look a one rook a six at
some point double on a file the of
course it depends on what black is doing
some has come in impossible but also it
could be possible to play the save on
the kingside something connected with
maybe h4 at some point maybe g4 there
are lots of plans forward to what can
follow and black has to pretty much
defend however it was the best hold
black could do basically stay kind of
sit tight there with knight on f6 and
don't do anything kind of like
extravagant who like 95 for instance so
coming back to this position after ruby
one dinkler played 95 and after before
which is very strong move takes takes
Ruby 5 has to go rubella right now is
very passive and b5 because otherwise 25
is lost and right now can be free white
is just much better
tink if we look at this position from
canvas if we just don't calculate
anything but just evaluate and you know
understand what's going on where the
action goes on this position where what
white wants what could be how the pieces
are placed and so on
first of all black has worst pawn
structure point if I was a weakness and
black has free pole Islands white pieces
for instance rooks are more active than
black robes relative strength of pieces
is definitely in white favor because we
work on b5 is a very passive piece it
just depends upon b5
sorry d5 but it doesn't do anything
about apart from that and also could be
at the object of the attack and rook
Blazek basically black groups are forced
to defense white while the white rooks
are attacking finally kinks position
white King is where the action is
actually going on the Queen side slash
center and be free it just does very
good job and position would be probably
around equal if black King would be here
basically covering the Queen side hovers
on g8 and you know interests just a very
concrete game it's very dynamic game
10-piece mean a lot
so if black could basically just
magically transfer King to seven
position be pretty much equal however if
King g8 it's far from equal because it
this King is not there and why let's say
quayside pawns black queen saipan pawns
can be easily attacked by white so for
instance I mean they can have a new king
of eight and of course right now rook a1
very through ver strong move by Magnus
the idea is to play after a six to play
rook a5 and the idea is to eliminate
this b5 rook which is yes it's badly
placed but that's very important the
fancy fact function of definitely five
point if this rock is traded 25 will be
even weaker than this and the other will
be forced to anyway defend this pawn on
d5 and
after takes takes will pretty much only
move otherwise you know would be very
bad pawn structure anyway so in this
position pawn defies force force to be
defended but also this pawn structure
sorry this pawn structure is definitely
in white favor because pawn beside is
potential weakness as well so black has
simply two witnesses pawn b7 and d5 so
right now I consider it two moves what
is clearly better what is clearly where
there is no any doubt about that
however in this position I think Bingley
I made a big mistake because he played
move e5 and this I think is a losing
mistake I will not I would not be too
hesitant to claim this is a losing
mistake because of the line that I have
that I will show in a moment but you
know it's it's a very very instructive
and very and very illustrative anyway so
we will get there in a moment
and let's think what could be better
move the bottom and my opinion sorry
once again rookie five what could be
wrong with this move and what is wrong
with this move is that basically f4 in
which what was is what Marcus didn't
play but this simply challenges this
rook immediately and rook from e5 is
forced to be very passive on H v square
and I think that for I mean first of all
it's impossible to play rookie four
because it would be five and wait yeah
here and basically even the King can go
forward and also there are ideas of you
know maybe training Lucas rubies at some
point it's with winning position for a
feint just came before it's pretty much
nearly doing for white and go to go for
a you know this b7 pawn also it's
possible as possible to play move like
Rudy eight and so on so also y has to be
careful about that
so therefore if R is not really a thing
in Ruby h5 will gather in moment but by
see that's what I'm trying to say is
that aphorism mistake is f4 wins for
white however if in this position black
would stop at four or like make make
this for a little bit less drunk by
playing g5 first position becomes kind
of you know
I will not say holdable but definitely
much harder to win for white then it was
there would be after Ruby 504 well
that's a rich if I was taking before was
the logical move to bring this king
forward rookie five and let's say a four
yeah a four and the or g3 I was thinking
about try to trace this rook away anyway
but I for already trades one pair of
pawns and suddenly Ruby two is very
quick counter play that black and black
has here let's say vortex violent hg2
and it's not so easy because even Ruby
Ruby seven doesn't actually create a
threat because Robeson is impossible
possible
for instance this is not even a thing
because rook h2 Ruby seven rook takes
Ruby - right so black is winning it's
not possible to attach p7 points so
easily and otherwise black has more than
enough counter play to attack pollen H
to pawn fr also and create a passed pawn
on the King side for black so I think
that it's not so simple to play for twin
and this with with white instead the jig
free I was thinking but also raga 5f4
and right now g4 and again black to
looks for active counter play when we
were caged five at some point of course
the idea is to play King seven can bring
the king forward to coming to the center
/ Queen side and you know let's say if
this kingly seven
there are also ideas to play king c5 d
for so if this is not also our just roll
quickly also such idea so it's not easy
to bring skin forward anyway so I just
think that after let's say eight three
takes g4 rook f6
Group H to b6 trading right now getting
rid of the weakness
Ruby 5 let's say and you know suddenly
this is not easy to win anymore 4 4 4
wide so in this position g5 was I think
the best defensive chance for for black
even though this is still very hard to
let's say defender say from practical
point of view because moves like here
let's say this rook f5 and the g4 is not
easy to come up with with all computer
analysis that I performed here and I
came up with the best defense for both
sides but basically all of it what has
in common is the active defense try to
play row gauge fight at some point
create some pressure create some counter
play on our opponent post weak palms
create some witnesses for our opponent
and by playing let's say here h3 and so
on
we play immediately we find we could
read actively dynamically from our own
weaknesses by playing b6 again this is
very timely and it's just very you know
accurate way of defending here so this
was the best defense and the problem
Ruby 5 is again this is you know
reacting toward what white is doing not
actually trying to create our own
chances with with black I think at least
because rookie 5 ok our point if I was
attacked so let's defend it first of all
on d5 is not really attacked because we
can play a rookie free after up defied
rookie free always so it makes sense to
play g5 first in order to gain some
space and actively creating potentially
some weaknesses on the kingside this
does the idea and thinking here instead
after Ruby 5 right now f4 we gauge 5 I
was thinking is the best move to again
gain Tempe on h2 pond but H very simply
and right now black has simply two moves
either King g7 or d4 and to be honest
none of them solve any problems I think
both boldly to winning positions for
white for instance analyzed if
differences d4 you know this this move
typically you know should be considered
at first because you get rid of the
poor weak Pondy five and tries to trade
it for the a five point and you know
seemingly it's just trading you know
weak pawn for you know for another pawn
and getting rid of the weakness and it's
alright however from principle point of
view this is alright but however
interest it takes before rook takes a
five and right now while his one
brilliant move that wins the game and
this move is rookie free cookie Frieza
I'm a pinion very cunning beautiful move
that it's also very educational
illustrative because rook is running
rock only free is cutting the King on
the ephah and with vol spawns secrete D
for supported by the king especially
this default pawn I should maybe put it
like this especially the four point
support of the King will simply promote
the Queen the King c4 d5 d6 was just
coming in so there only path right now
for black I was thinking is again active
concave some g5 and trying to you know
confuse you know make some complications
let's see if G Friedan she takes a for
may be played in G the safe g3 then G
fgf rook f5 to try to create some Condor
play provoke AfriNIC was kingly seven if
we for maybe Luke h5 could be some
chances to make a drug here however
white has again very nice way to win the
game with rookie five and transform this
to the pond end game after up 35 ft 5
this endgame Poland game is one for
white of course it's very hard to find
over the board but you know if you would
say I'm just like I'm not criticizing
Magnus or anything right now that you
didn't do it it's of course very hard to
play and first of all this a foreign
stand when you know first of all hear
him before in this position it's very
natural to play and easy to miss miss
miss understand or misjudge that f4 is
much stronger but I was so in the moment
why
so this line would deform and this what
we discuss karaoke 5 this is simply
winning for white as an my analysis
indicates because after king e7 came
before King versus remove King goes to
c5 and b6 and been basically then C D
and E pawn just go forward there is no
way to stop them and after let's say
Kings Kings file just wins
I thought only defenses for black would
be just b6 but then the sorriness d5 but
c4 first if the king de 7 just e5 and
the of 1375 is just winning there is no
way to and white pawns are just much
more advanced than black pawns here and
there is no way to you know to save this
put game with with black if I can be 5
just wins if h5 we can go C 6 and after
h4 is just King c4 black cannot create
any passport on the King side in order
to deflect our King from you know going
I mean from the pawns on Queen side and
if let's say right now we can go over
keep the king side and even if black
starts pushing the horse pawns on a quiz
I will be much faster to create a
passport on the submersible support by
the King on the King side so there is no
way black can make it rock here also
when I'm very lucky with a sample some
tubes rank which causes immediate
collapse of the blacks position because
right now I think it's already too
strong because if King goes back to c8
or da theirs g6 and you know pause going
in further if B 5 or a 5 then King comes
to 5th rank of King before King c5 then
it's pretty much game over here what is
simply winning so this important game is
winning only attempt for by blacks to
play h5 here d5 and f6 I thought but
this allows ecigs
after King d6 otherwise c5 f f5 and c5
was just much faster 26 right now only
important move right
then use to play g4 and the idea is that
as I was saying earlier white needs to
make sure that black doesn't create a
passport on the kingside because then
black would win actually but with g4 we
fixed the kingside and it's pretty much
game over because white pawns are simply
more more and more advanced than black
pawns and there is no way black can you
know even hope for a draw here for
instance f-84 doesn't matter actually
84-84 doesn t matter at the King C
freaking seven kingdoms ex-king g4 if I
five sonic cooking at five and king of
67 just wins so if this if fi happened
earlier we can do just coking C freaking
be freaking a foreign King B 5 we need a
game anyway so that's pretty much game
over it is in this position but very
important move after D for dis dis
rookie free this is I really want to pay
attention to his move
because rope only free just covers the
e-file and prevents blacking from go
join in the King side Queen side so the
but the other defense would be keenly
seven to bring this King to the Queen
side or sunder immediately however this
fails to Rupp d4 and ideas look before
and that's the big important thing very
for waiking before is a mistake what
Magnus played King before is a mistake
because sometimes this rook wants to go
for d4 to before and by playing move
here a four row gauge v h3
in g7 right now Rob d4 root comes to
before and attacks b7 pawn and puts lots
of pressure on the second weakness to
only defy boss of b7 pawn because our
two weaknesses so right now King d6 also
King the same as possible but doesn't
change much for instance Kim G 6 and if
for very important move King c5 and d5
and this critical idea to you know play
45 whenever given a chance because of
the spin on the D file and right now the
idea of rupee for simply decide decides
the game for instance regret for a fall
is the best defense hero before king
right now it's time to bring our King
back and after King c2 king who goes
towards the basically you know III
square or a pretty much every square
root b6 follows and slowly Ruby see this
is slowly white simply wins because
we're going to h4 is misplaced
I mean so far for now is well placed but
it could be easily neutralized if we if
we bring our King to e3 and prevent a
four point and our hope from before
Cain's go to be 66 and collect lots of
lots of pawns
so here I thought b5 could be a best
chance for a black to make a drafter it
takes be 5/8 X b6 and pass on King b7
and the idea is you know to block this
pawn somehow over the King and try to
play a five against some dynamic active
counter play but right now what wins
simply by force and this very nice idea
which might has here f5 and after rogue
h5g for rock days h3 Simulink block is
you know got back the palm and black
rook is still kind of active but right
now wife has stunning move an expat
extremely effective rook to e4 and after
oogi four wins the game on the spot
because after detects e 4 is 6 ft x e6
ok check we can run a check it can be
free takes takes what a 6-pound is not
it's not possible to stop because if
king c6 b7 goes in and our King we have
pretty much after community 6 e 7 let's
say this this b7 just promotes the Queen
there is no way to stop this pawn so
basically this is just game over
this is what is winning and thanks to
this beautiful idea of rookie 4 but why
is it all possible because what had this
through before idea initially took you
know that cradles chances here and
that's why I really believe that this
move
four wins the game at least all the
lines I analyzed and I you know prepared
I think this is simply winning for white
but the idea is to keep more options in
hand not only can be forking in c5 but
also roopd for before and Ruby six and
this is I think very important in take
from this end game that you know this
rope can go from before to this for
default to before and then to attack
this b7 pawn second weakness because
what Magnus plate that's fine I see what
Marcus played he played him before and
this is already not so clear to me
because I think are talking before
positions nearly drowned this is I think
huge I've discover if you know that
after King before positions nearly drawn
and the England defender perfectly and
achieved rorish position which we'll
discuss him quickly what happened King
g7 f4 and right now rogue a try it's
also possible for instance after h3 King
the six before the same thing right if
five row gauge for Ruby for in the same
position which could have been the game
but again I mean the previous line with
a fork but the thing is if King on it
before is not so easy to win it because
normally we would like to have a broken
before and our King goes to e free King
Bob came before his very misplaced so it
is not so simple to win it with white
cover of course what is still much
better so it was possible but still why
this better but is not so you know easy
however well I really like what Dingley
rendered because he went for active
counter play it because rogue a try
would be passive Ruby for its active you
just give track your attack your
opponent's weaknesses and you keep your
active so this is the best defense by
Dingley run right now 65 right now the
White King goes forward however okay for
attacking the pawn a5 King b6 and King
g6 if can be some of course rogue a5 no
problems pawn defies when the right now
also what protected by the king - that
decided to play route before but right
now group is being
divided over gave three and right now
pawn c3 is being attacked so it's not so
easy for Magnus to make progress here
anymore
and after a four rwby free check King
c70 takes e4 right now opponent besides
again protected rook takes e4 King f5
and again this was I think critical
position where moms had maybe one chance
to create some practical difficulties
for back here
however position objectively shall be
drawn after a king basically what I'm
trying to say is that the fence since
this moment also quickly once again
since this moment can be 14-7 every word
England was doing was very active very
dynamic defense a fourth check King c5
attacked the our opponents weakness King
b6 King g6 defender pond and again go
for activate the rogue to the maximum
raga free if for track and djz for our
just in compared this position we've
Rubin be free to the one we discussed
here with rook on h5 right just to bring
it quickly to show it let's say this
position Rubin h4 is simply misplaced
it's just
and we've accurately what - could have
achieved that however in this position
with Rubin be free is not simple anymore
we're gonna be free is very active
attacks policy free defense pawn b7 does
lots of functions and also potentially
threatens Ruby to to attack those pawns
and ideally create a counter play on the
Queen King side by creating past pounder
so this is the pass defense by biting
Lorraine so right now - Peru before
which is possible however I think Ruby 7
gave a little bit more chances and here
I think the best defense by being the
one who have been f6 and this could have
been not an easy move to play you know
there could be removes Akita is a four
maybe
see free also you know possibly the
black could play however f6 would be
certainly one of them but there is some
room for error at least so f6 and if I
thought that basically either white can
make I mean protects upon octagon g7
none of them regard any series winning
chances positions should be pretty much
drawn for instance after c4 g6 we
protect upon simply G free route before
again actively creating some control
chances c5 Ruby 5 again attacking this
c5 pawn and a fat 196 but right now
there are no frets right now there are
no first Pumbaa Sun is protected pawns
okay we cannot take on i-5 because Ruby
7 wins profit also protected but also
upon mission is protected and there is
no immediate threat so it's time to
create counterplay again g5 the crew
black is creating image control and the
King side to wear black king is in order
to hopefully create a passed pawn and
look for contour chances like that for
instance after taste this I thought h3
could be interesting but let's say G for
h4 and King g6 and again a5 a4 could be
an idea and or or Group B free also like
there are serve several ideas for black
that you know that could try to use
engage 5 for instance in 7 would be 5
again look for Condor brave on pawns d5
I don't think black here he's black
I mean what has hear anything so this is
one possible line another possible line
after f6 is route 87
pass through p5 is important to
eliminate this a 5 point which is much
more important pawn on c3 because if
rook C free obviously can be seven point
six is lost white wins
however if we eliminate one on a5 even
though this person will be in the with
rook and gain down upon without the
opponent on a5 the likelihood of a draw
is like it's pretty pretty big so
seven rook takes a five grouped xh6
for instance if kita seven rugae - we go
for counter play on the kingside and we
eliminate this pawn G to Poland for is
also following groups - is active
defense as well I don't think there are
any real chances for for black to for
white to to win because after c4 also
it's a five which has to be considered
at least Black has more than enough
resources to make a draw here if rook
takes h6 however we can just even
protect this point on p7 point would be
five or something like b5 or yeah b5 or
okay - we can go for the same stuff also
b5 and you know with such active rook
and a selective King only thing not
blundered okay Ruby try obviously but if
we play a b5 or okay - or every all
those moves are pretty much around equal
so rookie free maybe not exam not not
it's not precise because King b7 but
rogue a - for instance looks pretty good
or same as move like b5 I think it's
very close to to a draw so - desert
decided player before after Luke takes
c3 team takes b7 of course Roxy - active
active defense attacking this G to pawn
and H 2 pounds G to H two pawns and if G
free save King King a 6gv what is what
man who's played after King after King
takes a six rupees G to h4 f 6 is very
strong move ideas to please him v g5
create a passed pawn trade of the you
know to trade F power F and H pounds and
have a sim sim simply g5 pawn and then
give black rook for the a pawn and
promote this trip on to the Queen and
white group will have to be given for
this pawn or a queen and will be
basically King versus King so it's a
draw for instance
after Kim b5 for instance g5 takes takes
takes takes a sixth is pretty simple
endgame just row gauge to route comes
for AJ to stop this a pawn engage six
Luka eight only move but it's sufficient
rook b8 rocked a c7 King textile and g4
and the White King is simply too far
away look if I check for instance
through g8 King goes in but in the
foreign King F to look away and the king
he won and simply draw so this is one of
the example lines a what could have
happened in here after King Day is a six
magnificent play g3 but this doesn't
really help either way because pH
talking a6 kingi for that King is anyway
active pawns if it's a problem
Ruby free rook a to and right now
Mongoose played King b6 and the game
ended because the England disconnected
and Marcus was our there I was awarded a
win so pretty dramatic and for dinner in
this game however Magnus showed huge /
fair play by simply giving up his next
game so it was very nice from Mongoose
my opinion but talking about this end
game this is simply draw this is this
very simple draw right now so it's not
surprised what Magnus did because if he
was winning here alcohol incentives you
know okay he was winning and he you know
however the win so it makes sense that
you know he's he was already win and so
on but like positions just a draw it's
also pretty easy draw so just to show it
quickly what could have happened
a-five a-six g5 basically same idea we
create a passed pawn on the King side as
black and there is nothing white can do
Ruby 5 contains g3 bouquet 5 and right
now nice move Ruby to bring the Rope
back to the you know 8 Frank takes takes
if we got five of course just g4 we
don't care
and if eight Queen takes takes a four
there are many ways to make a draw but
this is one of the simplest ones and
this is just just kinky for everyone
queen Ruka Raghavan king of wanking at
5:00 just to show it quickly kinky for
f1 this disking f5 draw right so that's
yeah so in this position
Magnus was our the wing because dinkler
and disconnected however position was
that just the draw so it just shot
what kind of brilliant defense a degree
represented ever since he was given a
chance but one basically this I want to
point out again this idea here of f4
immediately ok dynamically creating a
winning chances an idea of Roop de Fora
before is very powerful and other idea I
want to point out that this thing with
d4 and here rook takes rook III cover
kicking cutting this King on the e-file
is also very very impressive in my
opinion so this was ring for Magnus but
then ever since this moment my dignity
represented great defense and great
defensive skills so and it was all about
dynamics now overall about the numbers
in this and came so yeah that's all I
have I think for today it wouldn't get
in time to talk about the last game that
I prepared for today about Magnus
winning with black pieces the final game
in blitz I was also very interesting but
you know sometimes I thought I showed
already lots of interesting things
especially in the last game market of
Marcus versus Bingley Ram so I hope this
was instructive and helpful
I personally think that this rook
endgame was very interesting it was
there were lots of chances
not-not-not quite often it doesn't help
it doesn't happen often that a white
king is goes to b6 and you know or like
that acting working before is a mistake
and
there were lots of things going on I
think but general think that dynamic
play usually is better or you know
preferential at least to the passive or
let's say passive or not the very
dynamic play and no matter we are
attacking or defending because it
applies to both in my opinion so that's
all I have for today I think and thank
you for watching me and see you next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]